(electronic music)
(printer whirring)
- You might have read
that the novel coronavirus is mutating.
That it's changing its genetic
sequence as it spreads.
That's very true.
Scientists have examined the sequences
of hundreds of viruses taken
from people around the world,
and some are starting to
diverge from one another.
The term mutating coronavirus
might sound alarming,
but it shouldn't be.
So far during this pandemic,
mutations have not been a bad thing.
In fact, they've been a bit useful.
- And we're gonna try to
visualize why that is.
With an inkjet printer and a Sharpie.
(electronic music)
- A virus is essentially a loose strand
of genetic material surrounded
by a protein-based wrapper.
Viruses exist to make
copies of themselves.
They spread by entering a host
and hijacking its cells to replicate.
Mutations are a natural
by-product of that process.
The protein that's in
charge of making copies
of the virus' genes inside a cell,
called a polymerase, can make mistakes.
Sometimes it'll slip in an adenine
in a spot where there's
supposed to be a guanine.
Other times, multiple different viruses
can also end up in the same host body.
If they both dump their
genes into the same cell,
some bits and pieces
can get swapped around,
and an entirely new virus is created.
That process is called recombination.
It was likely some kind
of recombination event
that created the new coronavirus.
Scientists think that a coronavirus
from a bat swapped some genes
with another coronavirus,
maybe from a different animal.
That may have triggered a
change in the spike protein
on the virus, the part that binds to cells
and lets the virus hijack them.
In this case,
the protein became good
at binding to human cells,
so when by chance it found
itself in a human eye or nose,
it could easily latch onto a cell.
It started churning out copies of itself
and jumped to another person, and another,
until it spread around the globe.
Now that the virus is here,
future mutations could change
how it acts, in theory.
Mutations that create beneficial traits
are more likely to stick around,
whereas those that could harm
the virus tend to fade away.
For a virus, a beneficial
mutation might be one
that helps it spread by
staying airborne longer,
whereas a harmful mutation might be one
that kills its host too quickly,
limiting its opportunity to spread.
Those kinds of changes could
happen with this virus,
but none of them seem to be happening.
A viral genome in New York
City might look different
from one in Washington State,
but the viruses are functionally the same.
Someone who is infected
with a New York virus
probably isn't going to
be any better or worse off
than someone who was infected
with a Washington virus.
There are different lineages of the virus,
but there don't seem to
be different strains.
It's an important distinction.
A new strain would have a
different biological property,
like staying airborne longer.
A few apparently neutral changes
to the genetic code don't meet that bar.
So why haven't new strains appeared?
Well, it's partly because
this virus is comfortable.
It's already evolved in ways
that make it really good
at thriving in humans and
spreading between them.
So it's not under a lot
of evolutionary pressure
to get even better at those things.
It also has to do with this
particular type of virus.
The coronavirus is an RNA virus,
and those usually mutate fast.
Unlike DNA, RNA doesn't
have built-in tools
to repair the mistakes made
in the copying process.
But coronaviruses like this one
actually do have proofreaders built in.
They double-check that
they're not making mistakes
when they copy themselves,
so they're less likely to
slip in the wrong nucleotide.
That means today, virus samples
from all over the world
look pretty similar
to the one that first emerged in Wuhan.
Many people who have COVID-19
are infected with viruses
that are less than 10 nucleotides
different from any others.
The full genome is around
30,000 nucleotides long,
so those changes are pretty minuscule.
That's good for vaccines and treatments.
It means the virus isn't
changing fast enough
that drugs and vaccines
would stop working.
If a drug works now,
the specific bit of the virus it targets
is not likely to change or vanish.
But the pace of mutation,
however slow, is useful to us.
It helps scientists track how
and where the virus is moving.
If two people have the same mutation,
it could mean that their
viruses are closely related,
and that they're part of
a cluster of infections.
Mutations are how experts
were able to track New
York's COVID-19 outbreak
back to a European lineage.
So mutations happen.
They're part of the
natural rhythms of a virus.
They're not inherently good or bad.
Scientists are watching them closely,
but they're not expecting
a science-fictiony monster movie scenario.
What we see is probably
what we're gonna get,
at least for a little while.
The challenge is understanding it.
(electronic music)
If you wanna stay up to date
with all of The Verge's
coronavirus coverage,
head over to theverge.com,
thanks for watching,
and don't forget to subscribe.